Susan is in Los Angeles hi Susan how are
you hi Dave I'm excited to talk to you
you too what's up well I have sort of an
unusual situation and my fiance and I
are about to get married in October
congratulation be be step thank you or
baby step three individually both of us
and so about a month ago I went on a
game show and I won a car and a bunch of
other things way to go
thank you it was kind of crazy can you
talk about which one is it okay I don't
think so okay because of what I'm going
to tell you next which is a month later
a few weeks ago my fiancee went on to
the same game show and won a car is well
it's insane right
absolutely well it got me out of my
lease which was fantastic and got a you
know out of debt which was awesome so I
have my car and after his show airs he
would be able to get his but the
question was we're looking to pay for
our wedding obviously we're going to
cash flow it and I wanted to know should
we keep the car should we lose the help
sell them both one of them what do you
what would you recommend
have you got an advice on the tax hit
yet well I have yes um because it's
pretty substantial on gameshow stuff in
California yeah so basically we had to
play sales tax for the for the items
which is very minimal and then it will
count as income on our next year's tax
return isn't there a special tax in
addition to the regular income tax not
that I've been told they just said it it
would just be the count as income tax
okay I want you to go back and
double-check that I know I'm not a tax
expert but I if it's if it's not there
it used to be that California dinged you
and even the IRS at one point had a
special extra ding for game show stuff
okay they just took an extra pound of
flesh and
so you need to be prepared for that
number or wenting I'm sorry it's
expensive to win things yeah yeah I mean
you got to come up with cash and so you
end up selling some of the stuff to keep
the other stuff so to speak so what's
the car worth so the first one we won
was a Fiat top so it was worth like
nineteen thousand was MSRP we probably
wouldn't get that for it right and then
the other one was a Mini Cooper and that
was worth around 23 yep all right one
thing you can do and I've had people do
this if you don't want the car is you
can talk with the dealer and they'll
make you a deal on it right on we
actually tried that but we weren't
allowed to do that okay all right
sometimes they do sometimes they don't
depending on the game show and what the
arrangement is with the manufacturer and
that kind of stuff so alright so you got
the car titled and you got to run resell
it you're going to lose money on it
that's part of the process neither one
of these are super expensive cars
what are you get money saved for your
wedding not a lot we're working on like
I said baby steps three come on along
maybe like three thousand okay and how
are you going to pay for the wedding and
how much is it well we're working on
that but we're just gonna you know what
we could save and up until now you know
getting deposits on places and things
like that right now but what would you
what is your what is your income and
what is his income I would guess or my
income is about 47 and his is about 40
okay and so what would be your ideal
wedding budget yeah maybe from what
we've looked at well my deal budget
would be about five thousand dollars but
I would say maybe ten is more realistic
centered um obviously so would you
rather have a ten or fifteen thousand
dollar wedding or one of these cars I
mean because you just have that you have
that option of selling it and turning it
into a wedding fund and buy and you know
driving a four thousand dollar car yeah
well what are your thoughts on buying or
having a youth car you know my parents
sort of say if you have the new car then
you don't you have the warranty and you
don't have to worry about fixing it so
it's less cost in that way and they all
break
and used cars don't break enough to
offset the difference in cost okay you
cannot financially justify owning a
newer car and a better car ever you can
just financially justify taking the hit
you know you make enough money to
justify owning these cars the only
question is you don't have any cash
would you rather have a wedding or have
one of these cars and that's just a
question you don't have to answer me
today but that's it is kind of that
simple if you dump one of these cars you
get a decent you know fifteen thousand
dollar wedding and you save up with is
eighty five thousand dollar income and
you're debt-free towards uh towards
moving up in car later you move up in
car later you can't move up in wedding
later that's a great point
so I mean I'm not suggesting you spend
fifty thousand bucks on the wedding but
I might be tempted to trade one of these
cars I won and I didn't know was coming
towards you know some miscellaneous
bills a honeymoon some wedding bills
making sure I got the cash set aside for
whatever taxation is involved in all
that kind of stuff and if I'm in your
shoes I might be willing to make that
trade um because it's kind of found
money I mean it's like woo
you know you you know the little cheer
you gave when you won the thing so you
might pick one of these or the other
that you think okay three years from now
do I want to be driving this car was a
Fiat in the Mini Cooper if I remember
right you know I want to be driving
those two cars five years from now or
did we just land in them because we
landed in them you know and it might be
that you'd rather you know he might
rather have a pickup or something I
don't know I'm just making this up and
might not be true in Los Angeles but
anyway might be but so you know you just
you got to decide and just look at it
that way and I'm probably going to move
that way if it's me but that doesn't
mean that it's necessarily the smart
thing to do neither with nothing on the
page here is in the dumb column so it's
just a matter of preference